but h5 in the end but okay you got to  just play this is bishop c2  or or even sack on h5 i mean what's the  worst that can happen  yeah there's bishop c2 so if you want to  does rookie one check maybe yes but what  about rookies the queen c7 check like  this king might get made it  it really my queen d6 check i don't know  we should play this  bishop f5 so i can tip and i fly with my  knight amazing cash from  oh my god five is incredible the thing  went oh my he played it  oh my gosh unbelievable that is the move  of the day  that is incredible and knight h1 rook  takes h1  oh my gosh this is mate everywhere got a  maiden now  don't botch the king g4 queen g3 okay  okay there's no immediate made by taking  on g2 should be good enough or h5  check 92 92 take the queen and run oh  my god model attack worthy of the  tall shirab you name the attacker  incredible